for the second year in a row as part of  the New York Comedy Festival we're  taking our show on the road to New York  City that's right that applies that is a  plan applause is a Los Angeles crowd  happy to get rid of it rid of us that's  right will once again be doing shows at  the historic Apollo Theater in Harlem  from November 6th through the 9th very  excited about that playing the Apollo is  such an honor we have some incredible  guests lined up and we'll be announcing  them in the next couple of weeks also if  you'd like to come see one of our New  York City shows in person head to team  koco.com  slash tickets for information be sure to  tune in we had a blast in New York at  the Apollo last year you do not want to  miss those New York shows all right  [Applause]  you